um me and about let's say eight Lads in
the
Gaff so having a little chill out and
then we're waking up to a lot of
commotion when I got up and looked i s
about
say four to five
gunmen all had B CLS and all had
silences this is what was crazy it was
like a movie so I remember getting up
after hearing a commotion seeing what I
seen and
instantly started running out of the
Airbnb obviously it was just a natural
reaction like what the hell's going on
I'm a high profile I got jewelry in the
place as I run out of the
building man's been
shot I remember running as fast as I can
but I remembering a loud bang buff and
my leg freezing
up I mean not
moving